Hi, my name is Chris Gagne
and I'm an Agile coach.
Today, I will talk about The Agile Manifesto.
The Agile Manifesto was written in early 2001.
A group of 17 very opinionated experts
specializing in extreme programming or "XP"
scrum, DSDM, and several other frameworks
got together for a weekend working session
at a beautiful ski Lodge in Utah.
While they didn't agree on much,
they did come to agreement on this
powerful Agile Manifesto.
It describes the fundamental values upon which the principles and practices of Agile rest
if you are effectively delivering software in total harmony with these values and the principles
you are agile
So what's the manifesto? It's almost poetic.
Goes like this:
We are uncovering better ways of developing software
by doing it and helping others do it.
Through this work, we have come to value
individuals and interactions
over processes and tools
working software
over comprehensive documentation
customer collaboration
over contract negotiation
and responding to change
over following a plan
That is while there's value in matters on the right,
we value the items on the left more.
Keep these values and the agile principles in mind
as you inspect and adapt how your team works together
Good luck and have fun!